hello and welcome to Rochford District
matters the magazine produced by the
council for its residents this is the
Winter 2014 edition
in this Edition are articles on
extending your home the ancient
Woodlands the best head teacher award
flood Forum takes action pledge for
Plastics a change in Rochford District
Council Bank details and much more but
the first item is the Chairman's year so
far
I was honored to be elected by my
colleagues to serve as chairman of
Rochford District Council in June this
year aside from my formal duty of
chairing Council meetings I've had the
privilege of being able to attend a
number of events already in my ear and
I've met so many of you
our district of Rochford is fortunate to
have many active organizations and
groups who work for the benefit of those
within the district
I spent an enjoyable day earlier this
year attending the first disability
exhibition staged by disability Essex
based in Rochford
this exhibition showcased the many
disability AIDS information and services
provided to disabled people
I was also able to meet many people and
learn more about how these AIDS and
services have led them to lead a more
independent life
I attended a concert at the Mill Hall by
Young music leaders from Rayleigh
six groups of talented musicians from
the fitzwimark school had led music
sessions at six primary schools within
Rayleigh and these ensembles had created
and composed their own music
the range and maturity of the music
composed was breathtaking and showed how
well our young people can work together
July saw the ravs Rayleigh Rochford and
District Association for voluntary
service AGM and awareness day and it
brought together information and
services to assist the more vulnerable
residents in our area
I also had the privilege of meeting many
older residents who attended the
community older persons event held
recently
the day focused on a range of subjects
from home security to fire safety with
many other subjects in between such as a
chair fit taster session to meeting Max
a pet therapy dog
this year marks a hundred years since
the beginning of the first world war and
I had the privilege of attending a
candlelit service at the Royal British
Legion Memorial in Rayleigh organized by
the Royal British Legion Rayleigh branch
on August the 4th
on the same day the council also
participated in the lights out campaign
this saw all municipal buildings
darkened with just one lamp left a light
in a window
one of the buildings used the windmill
in Rayleigh also hosted a very
interesting and thought-provoking
exhibition mounted by Rayleigh through
the Looking Glass
which highlighted the impact of the
first world war on Rayleigh
although this year marks the start of
the first world war do look out for
other events throughout the next four
years as we continue to remember those
who served and fell during this terrible
battle
with Remembrance Day on November the
11th I had many invitations to local
events which I was honored to attend
it is important we all go along to the
events organized by the Royal British
Legion branches in Rochford District to
remember those who died in 1914-18 and
in all conflicts since then
your Council also hosts a number of
events for our residents
I had the privilege of attending Wild
Woods day on a gloriously hot day and
participated in many of the free events
on offer
I also spent two days walking around and
meeting many of the artists who
participated in the Rochford Art Trail
this year
it was fantastic to see the range of
work and I do hope some of you were able
to buy many of the works of art on offer
these are only a few of the many events
that I've been invited to attend so far
this year
if you'd like me to come along to an
event please contact Lynn Rackley Civic
officer on
318-144 or email
lynn.rackley at rochford.gov dot UK
in these uncertain Economic Times I know
many of you face difficulties in your
lives however as I have hopefully
highlighted there are a number of
organizations within the Rochford
District who are able to help you to
overcome these difficulties you can
always contact the council to find out
more
it only remains for me to wish you all a
happy and safe Christmas and New Year
and I hope to meet many of you in the
coming months councilor Mrs June Lumley
chairman Rochford District Council
another year sails by
it has been another busy year for the
award-winning Rayleigh windbill from
hosting storytelling evenings to holding
exhibitions and marking the first world
war centenary
the highlight of the Year by far was
winning the national museums and
Heritage award for customer service
Excellence which recognized the
exceptionally high levels of customer
service delivered by the windmill
volunteers it really has been a year to
remember
The Season's events kicked off with the
national Mills weekend where the
windmill volunteers dressed up in
traditional period costume and ran
guided tours
August saw the windmill look at its most
stunning as poppies which had been
planted to commemorate the first world
war bloomed just in time for the World
War One exhibition held by Rayleigh
Through the Looking Glass
Heritage Open weekend held in September
recorded the highest number of visitors
to date
there were workshops in storytelling
drama and arts and crafts for children
across both days as well as newly
acquired traditional periods for
children to dress up in
to top it all off the windmill secured
the quality assured visitor attraction
award from visit England for their sixth
year in a row and the venue has been
shortlisted as a finalist in the wedding
venue of the Year Heritage category of
the Essex wedding Awards
with the end of the year now in sight
keep an eye on
www.rochford.gov dot UK slash windmill
for more events in 2015 or follow the
windmill on Twitter at Rayleigh
underscore Mill
the railway Mill hosts a self-contained
exhibition space on the second floor
we're offering local artists and
voluntary Community groups the
opportunity to use the exhibition space
to promote their work or the work of
their organization
the windmill will be open on Wednesdays
Saturdays and Sundays from the end of
March to the end of September 2015.
there's no charge for exhibitions
artists or groups would be allocated an
approximate four to five week period and
will be expected to staff the exhibition
when the windmill is open
if you're interested in exhibiting or
you'd like more information please email
sophie.manus at rochford.gov dot UK by
Friday the 16th of January please
include a brief description of how you
propose to use the exhibition space
fifty thousand pounds funding pot to
help local businesses
a fifty thousand pound funding pot is
being made available to help local
businesses to expand and provide jobs
Rochford District Council has obtained
the funding from the business South End
growth Hub in order to support local
companies to grow while creating
unsafeguarding jobs across the district
businesses can apply for funding to
cover 30 percent of any project they are
planning which can range from helping to
fund a new website or to update one
already in place
the grant applications must be agreed by
a grants panel and are not project or
sector specific
if you would like to apply for funding
you simply need to get in touch with the
economic development team at Rochford
District Council
funding for projects will only be
available until February the 28th 2015.
the scheme will also enable businesses
to access a range of support including
tailored business advice mentoring and
one-to-one Specialists support
on top of this there will be a range of
workshops designed to inform and help
businesses across the area delivered by
Essex Chambers of Commerce
Innovation vouchers worth five thousand
pounds will be available for businesses
who want to access expertise and
specialist advice through Anglia Ruskin
and Essex universities
this funding is being provided via
business South End which was established
earlier this year after South End on sea
Borough Council secured 1.8 million
pounds to deliver a growth hub
the funding was secured from the
government's regional growth fund
through Lancaster University who are
leading the creation of 15 New Growth
hubs across the UK
the business south end program will
deliver business support grants
Innovation workshops and specialist
expertise and a range of events aimed at
supporting new growing and established
businesses this has now been made
accessible to all businesses across
Thames Gateway South Essex
to find out more call the economic
development team on 01702
546-366 or email business at
rochford.gov dot UK
businesses can also register on the
dedicated website www dot
businesssouthend.co.uk
5th annual Rochford Art Trail was a
blast
rochford's ever popular art Trail
returned for its fifth consecutive year
once again playing host to dozens of
artists who exhibited their talents in
the town shops cafes and businesses
during the 10-day exhibition droves of
people were seen walking the streets of
Rochford touching their maps showing how
effective the town can be as a visitor
destination
paintings photography glass Arts digital
illustration jewelry and textiles were
displayed in shops and businesses around
the town for visitors to view at their
leisure
and just as they thought they'd seen
everything yet another new attraction
would become available such as pop-up
arts and crafts market
silversmithing workshops a day of film
viewings and live theater performances
the Art Trail was the ideal chance for
local artists to display their work and
make new contacts and customers
it provided new and upcoming artists
with an exciting opportunity to practice
taking part in an exhibition boosting
their confidence and developing skills
that will continue to help them
throughout their careers
and it played a part in developing the
local community by drawing residents
into its heart the library and giving
young school children a unique
opportunity to get out and explore the
Arts together through fun workshops
inspiring their young minds what's more
local business was given a boost with
many people visiting Rochford for the
first time excitedly talking about what
a great find it is with its vast array
of quirky shops offering a variety of
gifts and homewares one visitor said
I've traveled through Rochford many
times but I've never stopped and looked
in the shops the Rochford Art Trail has
made me realize how many unique shops
there are in Rochford and in future when
I need a special gift or accessory
Rochford will be my first Port of Call
the 2014 Rochford Arts Trail is now over
but whether you're an artist wishing to
take part or an expectant visitor make
sure you look out for next year's events
and that will run from Thursday the 17th
to Saturday the 26th of September
be safe in Open Spaces
working an area for your own safety
please follow these Simple Rules
avoid entering the work site take an
alternative path
do not approach staff in a danger zone
stop and wait for staff to come to you
dog walkers as soon as you hear or see
Machinery or signage please control your
dog and attach its lead
horse riders we always look out for you
and will quickly shut down Machinery so
you can safely pass
for sale
firewood Chestnut fence steaks wood chip
which is great for mulching flower beds
and for chicken runs
Oak benches plus more items to follow in
the near future such as charcoal pea
sticks and bean poles
the woodlands and Open Spaces team would
like to thank all our regular visitors
for their care and consideration when
using the district's open spaces and
woods you are our eyes and ears please
continue to tell us of any issues or if
you see something rare or interesting
contact us if you have any questions or
sales inquiries or any other queries you
can call customer services on 01702
318-111 or email customer dot services
at
rochford.gov dot UK and more information
on the country's Woodlands is available
at
www.rochford.gov dot UK
www.naturalengland.org dot UK and
www.woodlandstrust.org Dot UK and just
follow the links
the head teacher of aureli secondary
school has been commended as the best in
the country
Andy hodgkinson of the Swain Park school
attended a national awards ceremony
where he was presented with the gold
Plato Pearson teaching Award for best
secondary school head teacher he said
this award is for the whole school
Community I'm fortunate to lead a school
with an incredibly committed and
hard-working staff effective Governors
and most importantly of all wonderful
pupils so the award is absolutely
something for us all to celebrate
he said it was also an exciting time for
the school having just opened its sixth
form in September
Rayleigh is an aspirational town with 35
000 inhabitants he said and so we felt
very strongly we wanted to give families
a greater choice in terms of post-16
education and enable pupils to stay in
the town if they wish to continue their
studies
chairman of Rochford District Council
councilor June Lumley said this award is
a tremendous achievement to be
recognized as the best secondary school
head teacher in the entire country it
really does make all the difference to
have someone who can lead from the top
and having met with Mr hodgkinson it's
clear to see just how enthusiastic he is
about the job
I'm delighted that we can offer such
first-rate educational opportunities in
the Rochford District
boundary review stage two
the independent local government
boundary commission for England or lgbce
is carrying out an electoral review of
Rochford District Council
stage two of the public consultation for
Rochford District Ward patterns will
take place between 9th of December 2014
the 16th of February 2015. this follows
their analysis and deliberation of
submissions received on Ward patterns
during the first stage consultation
during the stage 2 consultation period
the lgbce will publish its draft
proposals for new electoral Arrangements
new Wars and their boundaries and names
for public comment
your views will make a difference local
people know their area best that's why
they're asking what you think of the
proposed Ward boundaries
for more details and interactive maps
visit
www.consultation.lgbce.org.uk or
www.lgbce.org.uk
and have your say you can send your
views to the review officer in Brackets
Rochford local government boundary
commission for England
Laden house turn Mill Street London ec1m
5 LG you can email reviews at
lgbce.org dot UK or you can follow them
on Twitter at lgbce
there is a budget survey
2015-16 included in this issue of
Rochford District matters now it may be
difficult for some residents to complete
these forms on their own Rochford
District Council has confirmed that if
someone finds this difficult they can
call the Council on 01702
546-366 and help will be available
the survey is very detailed but we will
now give you an overview of what the
survey contains
section one gives you the opportunity to
select a priority for certain Services
high medium or low it also gives the
current cost per head of that service
the services in question are these
cultural and related Services the
windmill Leisure premises recreational
spaces
Planning and Development Economic
Development voluntary grants and
Community safety
Environmental Services
environmental health public conveniences
Street cleansing recycling collection
section 2 asks if you would be happy to
see an increase in council tax if it
avoided further reductions in service
Section 3 asks if you would be happy to
see an increase in the expenditure to
resolve flooding issues even where these
are not the district council's
responsibility
section 4 asks whether you would be
happy to see parking charges introduced
at Open Spaces in the district to
support those facilities
Section 5 would like to know your top
three issues that you would like the
council to deal with Section 6 asks what
services you think the council should
reduce or stop doing
section 7 asks how the council improved
access to its services
the closing date is Friday January the
16th
citizens advice Bureau is celebrating
its 75th birthday
the charity first opened its doors at
the outbreak of the second world war
offering advice from town halls
libraries private homes and even horse
boxes nowadays people can get advice
face to face over the phone and online
Rochford and Rady Cab's top inquiries
revealed Rochford and Raley cab is run
by eight staff and 70 volunteers who
helped
2568 people last year
between April and June 2014 the issues
most local people sought help about were
benefits
relationship issues family issues and
debt
Charities clean up
the results of Rochford District's
pioneering charity litterbins project
have been published showing a dramatic
reduction in litter levels in Rayleigh
the pilot a first for the UK
incentivized people to bend their litter
responsibly by linking the amount of
litter collected in the bins to
donations to local charities
on average over the course of the pilot
litter on the ground was reduced by 41.7
percent with the biggest reduction in a
single month being
53.38 percent
Rayleigh and Wickford MP Mark Francois
joined chairman of Rochford District
Council councilor June lumney Rose Tian
from keep Britain tidy and Mark Graham
from Wrigley which funded the campaign
at the Rayleigh windmill to award the
Charities their donations
as a result of the pilots the charities
ravs wyvern community Transport and the
mushroom Theater Company benefited by a
total of 1 331 pound and 50 pence which
will be put towards their activity in
the local community in Rochford
in August the BBC camera crew came to
ready High Street to film a documentary
focusing on the campaign during the
filming Council staff and waste
collection contractors also spoke about
litter on the town's streets and the
various methods Rochford District
Council are using to reduce it members
of the public were interviewed about
their views on reducing litter
Christmas and New Year collection days
for Rochford District Rochford District
residents are among the best in England
when it comes to recycling and we'd like
to say a big thank you for your help
with Christmas just around the corner
it's more important than ever that we
try to minimize our waste and recycle as
much as possible
and there are some changes to Christmas
collection days
recyclables Monday the 22nd Tuesday the
23rd and Wednesday the 24th of December
are all as normal
Christmas day Thursday the 25th will be
moved to Saturday the 27th
and Friday the 26th will move also to
Saturday the 27th
for your non-recyclables Monday the 29th
for Tuesday the 30th and Wednesday the
31st are all normal
Thursday the 1st of January 2015 moves
to Friday the 2nd and Friday the 2nd
moves to January Saturday the 3rd of
January please note there are no
compostables collections on Saturday the
27th recyclable only
reduce food waste and save money this
Christmas here's some top tips
take a look in your cupboards fridge and
freezer and make a note of what you
already have this will help you to avoid
doubling up when hitting the shops only
buy food that you actually need how many
people are you actually cooking for
prepare for meals and use leftovers
Tasty Recipes for leftovers can be found
on www.lovefoodhatewaste.com
Savvy storage freeze leftovers and visit
www.lovefoodhatewaste.com for new ideas
such as freezing wine and cheese
don't neglect your compostables bin this
Christmas you can compost fruit and
vegetable peelings raw and cooked food
Meat and Fish including the bones plate
scrapings and leftovers eggshells tea
bags tea leaves and coffee grounds bread
dairy products no liquids as well as
Garden waste
the citizens advice Bureau the cab
service provides free confidential and
impartial advice and information on a
variety of aspects of daily living
including finances if you live in the
district and would like to speak to an
advisor you can phone
0344-477-0808 Monday to Friday 9 30 a.m
to 4 P.M for initial assessment you can
email
www.rochfordcab.org dot UK or visit
their offices
the current opening hours for the
Rochford office in backlane Rochford
ss41ay Tuesday and Thursday 10 a.m to 2
P.M
the Rayleigh office at the Civic Suite
Hockley Road Rayleigh ss6 8eb Monday
Thursday and Friday 10 a.m to 2 p.m you
can also visit
www.adviceguide.org UK for useful
information and advice
cope safety event success
more than 40 residents filled Rayleigh
Baptist Church at the community older
persons event known as cope organized by
the castle point in Rochford District
Community safety partnership
the event funded by Rayleigh Town
Council and sponsored by The Cooperative
was held on National UK older people's
day and aimed to give the older
generation lots of information and tips
on how they can stay safe in their daily
lives the church Hall was packed with
different stalls and presentations
including Essex police advising on home
security the fire service talking about
carbon monoxide poisoning Pets As
therapy Alzheimer's Society citizens
advice Bureau and talking newspapers for
the blind
the chairman of Rochford District
Council councilor June Lumley who
attended the event said I was delighted
to see so many residents taking the
opportunity to get lots of advice and
tips on how they can feel safe and be
safe not only in their own home but
whilst out and about to find out more
about future cope events near you please
call Sophie Manis on 01702 318120
a KeepSafe scheme has been launched in
Rayleigh with 20 people signing up on
the day once people have signed up they
can go to a keep safe venue and ask for
help to contact a family member friend
or carer
local venues identified as safe places
provide free access to use of a
telephone or will make a call on behalf
of someone producing their KeepSafe card
if you wish to sign up to the KeepSafe
scheme please contact Community safety
on 01702 546366
Council of the Year Rayleigh Town
Council has been awarded Council of the
Year by the Essex Association of local
councils known as ealc
this prestigious award was presented at
the ealc's annual general meeting on the
18th of September 2014 when the chairman
councilor Eddie Dre and town Clark Kerry
Cumberland were presented with a
certificate and silver platter the
chairman of the ealc Sheila Jackman MBE
remarked in Her speech that the ealc has
100 membership of the total 274 parish
and town councils in Essex and Rayleigh
Town Council won this award by a long
way she was particularly impressed by
this town council's connection with the
local communities such as the Christmas
lights event and the annual visits by
school councils who are invited into the
council chamber to ask the chairman
questions Town Council chairman
councilor Eddie Dre said this is a
lovely award to receive and we are
immensely proud of this achievement
Raley Town Council has a strong team of
23 councilors and three members of Staff
who all show dedication and commitment
to working hard to get the best for our
town
crime-free Christmas many of us will be
preparing for Christmas with our
thoughts turning to what presents
friends and relatives would like
the same time another section of our
community is also thinking about
spending sprees sadly not theirs but
yours each year the papers are filled
with stories of car thieves and burglars
who take the opportunity to relieve us
of the gifts we've bought
before you leave home make sure your
house is safe and secure have a walk
around and think about how you'd get in
if you locked yourself out if you can so
could your not so friendly burglar
remember being secure is equally
important when you are home as when
you're out
don't leave parcels and presents on
display if you're out shopping and need
to drop items back to the car be sure to
lock them in the boot Parcels under the
Christmas tree look lovely but they are
a great advert if they can be seen from
the outside
if you're doing your Christmas shopping
online be on the lookout for scams and
frauds with more and more items being
bought on the internet there are plenty
of fraudsters who are Keen to access
your account details or sell something
dodgy
here's some help helpful tips for safe
online shopping
be careful when buying from people with
little or no history
check the item's description carefully
don't be afraid to ask questions
beware of people offering you a deal
below the current bid or reserve price
especially if they contact you direct
be aware of phishing emails that look
like they come from the online auction
or payment site you're registered with
asking you to update your account
details or re-enter them because your
account has been suspended
If you bid for an item unsuccessfully
don't be tempted to trade off-site if
another seller approaches you with a
similar item
for more information go to
www.essics.police.uk and follow the
fraud link or contact Rochford District
council's Community safety team on 01702
318-112 for a copy of fraud isn't just a
scam it's a crime which is a guide to
identifying and preventing fraud
disability sport sessions proved to be
ace
more than 40 people from all over the
district packed out stanbridge Memorial
Hall to try out some free disability
sporting taster sessions in a joint
initiative run by Rochford district
council at active Rochford Essex County
Cricket Board and stanbridge Parish
Council
sitting volleyball boccia and table
Cricket were all on offer and not only
proved to be great fun but also brought
out the competitive spirit in everyone
attendee Sue Camp said I didn't know
what to expect as you don't hear about
these things very often especially being
free of charge I had a great time who
would have thought I would be trying my
hand at a paralympic sport alongside a
paralympic gold medalist
the chairman of stanbridge Parish
Council George yanu said I would like to
thank everyone involved in making this
disability sport taster session a
success
the bar has been set to ensure
individuals of all age groups with
various disabilities have a structured
facility to enjoy the sporting
engagement and social aspect of future
events
paralympic botia gold medalist Dan
Bentley who is supporting the sessions
was also on hand to show off his skills
and encourage others to try out some
games
Mark Winship from forget-me-not day
Center said it's fantastic to see all
the volunteers who've given up their own
time to help make this event the success
it is and the fact that they had fun is
an added bonus we're really grateful to
the organizers for making sessions like
this possible and giving those who might
not have had the chance the opportunity
to try out a new and fun sport
a regular weekly session will start in
stanbridge this winter with all ages and
abilities welcome to come along
if you require Transportation please
contact us so we can discuss what
assistance we may be able to provide
for more information and notification of
dates and times contact Mark Aldous
Sports Development officer Rochford
District Council the telephone number is
01702-318-121 or you can email sport
rochford.gov dot UK
extending your home if you're thinking
about extending your home you can find
advice at
www.rochford.gov dot UK forward slash
planning forward slash advice or you can
call our planning team on 01702 546-366
an extension or addition to your house
is considered to be permitted
development not requiring an application
for planning permission subject to the
following limits and conditions
no more than half the area of land
around the original house would be
covered by additions or other buildings
no extension forward of the principal
elevation on side elevation fronting a
highway
no extension to be higher than the
highest part of the roof
single-story rear extension must not
extend beyond the rear wall of the
original house by more than three meters
if an attached house or by four meters
if a detached house
in addition outside Article 1 5
designated land and sites of special
scientific interest the limit is
increased to six meters if an attached
house and eight meters if a detached
house until the 30th of May 2016.
these increase limits between 3 meters
and six meters and between four meters
and eight meters respectively are
subject to the neighbor consultation
scheme
maximum height of a single story rear
extension of four meters
extensions of more than one story must
not extend beyond the rear wall of the
original house by more than three meters
maximum Eaves height of an extension
within two meters of the boundary of
three meters
maximum Eaves and ridge height of
extension no higher than existing house
side extensions to be single story with
maximum height of 4 meters and width no
more than half that of the original
House
two-story extensions no closer than
seven meters to rear boundary roof pitch
of extensions higher than one story to
match existing house
materials to be similar in appearance to
the existing house no Verandas balconies
or raised platforms
Upper Floor side facing Windows to be
obscure glazed any opening to be 1.7
meter above the floor
on designated land no permitted
development for rear extensions of more
than one story
on designated land no cladding of the
exterior
on designated land no side extensions
the term original house means the house
as if it was first built or as it stood
on the 1st of July 1948 if it was built
before that date although you may not
have built an extension to the house a
previous owner may have done so
designated land includes national parks
and the broads areas of outstanding
natural beauty conservation areas and
world heritage sites
this will be subject to the house having
permitted development rights in the
first instance these are sometimes
removed and the planning history of an
individual property would need to be
checked to confirm this
we would encourage people to apply for a
lawful development certificate to
confirm whether a proposal meets the
necessary permitted development criteria
if they are at all unsure or would like
formal confirmation from the council
this advice is a summary of the
regulations on extensions and detailed
advice should be sought before
commencing works
now with flooding who to call
the environment agency website contains
details of river level and flooding
information and can be accessed at
www.environment
hyphenagency.gov dot UK you can call
floodline on 0845-988
double one double eight
using quick dial
036343 for up-to-date flooding
information
if your property is either flooding or
is at immediate risk of flooding then
call Essex County Fire and Rescue
service using 999 but be aware that if
there is no obvious risk to life your
call will be prioritized and attendance
by the fire service may be delayed
you can call the environment agency
incident hotline to report flooding from
a main river or the sea on 0800 80 70
60.
report blocked gullies and Highway
drainage issues to Essex County Council
via the reporter problem page at www dot
essex.gov dot UK forward slash highways
or call 0845-603-7631
to report flooding from sewers call
anglian water on the 24-hour emergency
number
03457-145-145
general information on getting ready for
winter is available at www dot met
office.gov dot UK forward slash learning
forward slash get hyphen ready hyphen 4
hyphen winter
driving
through flood waters
many cars will start to float in as
little as 12 inches of water plus the
engine air intake on many cars is low
down at the front of the car just an egg
cup full of water ingested into the
combustion chamber is sufficient to
destroy an engine
only drive through flood water if you
know it's not too deep this will be no
deeper than the lowest part of the
vehicle's Bodywork
don't attempt to drive through fast
moving water such as at a flooded Bridge
Approach your car could easily be swept
away even at modest depths
with standing water physically test the
depth of the water with a pole weighed
in if necessary but only where it's safe
to do so or observe the depth against
other vehicles that cross successfully
but just because they are successful it
doesn't mean it's appropriate to follow
if in doubt don't
if you have to drive through water
select a low gear so the engine revs are
higher
slipping the clutch if necessary or for
automatic vehicle
select the lowest ratio and balance the
throttle and brakes
before entering consider other drivers
pass through flooded sections one car at
a time don't drive through water against
approaching forwarding Vehicles Drive
slowly and steadily to avoid creating a
large bow wave test your brakes as soon
as you leave the water if you get stuck
firstly ensure the safety of all
involved including other Road users do
not repeatedly try to start the engine
this may cause further damage call for
recovery and weight in a safe place
give change where it counts begging in
the Rochford district has become more
apparent this year in Rayleigh we have
seen individuals regularly begging in
prominent spots some do passively While
others can be more demanding
the harsh reality is that compassionate
handouts will encourage people who beg
to continue with their street lifestyle
rather than bringing about real and
Lasting change evidence shows many
people begging use this money to buy
drugs or alcohol and ultimately these
helps keep them on the streets
concerned individuals should know that
in Rayleigh we're spoken with these
people and very few have been homeless
Rochford District Community safety
partnership is working with a range of
organizations to properly support people
to Target their problems so they don't
need to beg and get the health and work
situation back on track and make some
lasting change in their lives
we'd ask you to consider giving instead
to Charities which can help make a real
difference in people's lives
we are working with Saint mungo's
Broadway a homeless charity and open
road who work with people affected by
drugs and alcohol
to make a donation go to
www.mongosbroadway.org UK or call 0208
600 300 or
www.openroad.org.uk or call 01206
369-782 lines are open 9am to 5 p.m
weekdays alternatively home hope work
operates a local reuse center for
furniture and electrical appliances and
needs donations you can call them on
01268-743232 or email info at hopework
and that is spelled
h-o-p-e-w-o-r-x dot org dot UK
help with your council tax if you are
getting council tax support and are
struggling to pay your bill Rochford
District Council has a dedicated officer
Lee Brown who can offer help and advice
you can call him on 01702 318-089
visit him at the council Offices South
Street Rochford between 8 30 a.m and 5
P.M Monday to Friday or request a home
visit if you find it difficult to get
out
Lee is working closely with the citizens
advice Bureau or cab and Murray refer
you to them for advice on budgeting and
managing debts
visit
www.rochford.gov dot UK forward slash
money advice for you useful information
and advice
you've been yours
Rochford District Council has taken part
in a campaign to reduce chewing gum
litter
encouraging residents to bin it your way
the council partnered with the chewing
gum action group or c g a g an
organization chaired by defra the
department for environment food and
Rural Affairs and funded by the chewing
gum industry to tackle gum litter in the
UK
the Rochford District saw a 64 decrease
in gum littered after the council took
part in last year's campaign this year
is set to be even better as several
major retailers joined the campaign as
well as local schools and businesses who
gave away chewing gum wraps to help
people bend their gum responsibly
I'm loving it
star from South End McDonald's have
again been helping to litter pick
problem areas with Rochford District
Council to encourage others to clear up
and take pride in where they live
the litter pick took place in the
district and involved volunteers from
Rochford District Council South End
McDonald's and Sita UK who all spent an
afternoon's work clearing up various
areas and ridding the District of
unsightly litter this is just one of the
many planned litter picks due to take
place throughout the district over the
next few months if you would like to
volunteer to get involved please contact
the recycling team on 01 702-318-111
Community it's great to volunteer
give your CV a boost in a recent survey
of some of the UK's leading businesses
73 said they'd employ someone who's
volunteered over someone who hasn't
gain time bank credits
participants volunteering time is
reciprocated with volunteer support in
return
it operates on the principle that time
is money and everyone can participate
this can involve practical skills such
as DIY or gardening sewing learning a
new language or playing board games and
sharing a cup of tea
improve your confidence
you'll learn and do things that you
might not normally get the chance to
which can be a real confidence boost
improve your health research has found
that volunteering can help you sleep
better and boost your immune system
meet new people
you could meet like-minded people that
you might not normally come across
get back into work it's a great way to
fill gaps in your work experience and
get a reference you can also try out
different types of work which can be
really helpful if you're looking for a
job or want to change direction
for a no obligation information leaflet
contact ravs on ravs at
ravs.org.uk or call us oh one two six
eight double seven two seven nine six
for an informal chat
Clan
plans to generate 6 000 jobs are a step
closer
thousands of new jobs a new modern
Business Park and Road improvements for
Rochford District are a step closer to
being realized as plans for London
Southend airport and surrounding land
near completion the London Southend
airport and environ's Joint area action
plan known as for short was
submitted to the government to be
examined in December 2013. following
public hearing sessions the government
inspector has set out the changes he
feels needs to be made to the plan so
that it is sound and therefore can be
adopted by the councils Rochford
district and Southend councils have made
these changes and we now await the
inspector's final report the jaap will
manage future development at the airport
as well as creating modern new business
space immediately to the west of the
airport known as Saxon Business Park
that will provide a wide range of job
opportunities it is anticipated that the
plans will lead to the creation of 6 000
jobs in total
in the last watch for district matters
we reported how advanced progress on the
preparation of the jaap had helped to
secure funding for new infrastructure in
the area this includes planned
improvements to the bell and kentelm's
interchanges on the a127 which will come
forward thanks to a growth deal set to
bring
442 point million pounds of government
investment to the southeast
it is expected that investment will
continue as plans are firmed up the jaap
is not just about economic growth though
it also includes controls that will
ensure development is carefully managed
in the interests of residents quality of
life and the local environment the plan
has evolved over time to account for
feedback from residents with thousands
of comments suggestions and ideas being
received throughout the process
the next stage is to await the
inspector's final report if it is found
to be sound it will then be for the two
councils to adopt the jaap through full
Council to find out more about the jaap
go to
www.rochford.gov dot UK forward slash
jaap
keep on running
free weekly Park runs are coming to
Hockley park run organizes five
kilometer timed runs all over the world
events are open to all free of charge
and safe and easy to take part in and
very soon park run events will commence
in the Blissful setting of Hockley Woods
Hockley runs will take place every
Saturday from 9am people of all
abilities are encouraged to participate
from those taking their first steps in
running to Olympians from Juniors to
experienced Runners all are welcome
volunteers are also needed to help with
marshalling timing barcode reading and
more call
07885-837324 for further information or
visit
www.parkrun.org dot UK get up get out
get running
the money advice service if you're
worried about your Financial Health ask
Ma
you can phone them on 0-300 500 5
trebolo Monday to Friday 8 A.M to 8 p.m
and Saturday 9 A.M to 1pm calls cost no
more than the standard cool they provide
free confidential and partial advice and
can help you with managing your money
better reviewing and reducing your
borrowing money saving tips Universal
Credit and other benefits work and money
bank accounts and credit and debit cards
visit
www.moneyadviseservice.org.uk for useful
information and advice
out and about
clubs and groups
events at Rochford Library Wishing Well
Center every Tuesday 9 45 to 10 15 am
stories and rhymes for babies and
toddlers
the job Club every Thursday 2 to 4 pm
get help and advice with building your
CV and searching for work
baby and toddler group every Friday 9 30
till 10 a.m stories and rhymes for Notch
to five-year-olds
Excel every Saturday all day what will
you discover
dial every last Tuesday each month 10 30
a.m to 1 30 PM disability information
and advice
care Mark every last Thursday each month
10 a.m to 12 noon advice on care and
support at home
computer training we can help you start
using a computer just ask staff for
details
the Rochford Martial Arts Academy
martial arts and Tai Chi classes for
adults and children
beginners classes are throughout the
week they're held at unit 2C Swain
industrial estate ashington Road
Rochford and beginner sessions are free
contact
01702-808-262 or info at
rochfordmartialarts.com or
www.rochfordmartialarts.com
art classes are suitable for beginners
and more experienced students
Monday 10 a.m until 12 noon Tuesdays 10
a.m till 12 noon and 1 to 3 P.M
held at the women's Institute Hall
Bellingham Laney Rayleigh contact 01702
615-475 or email Paula 43
yahoo.co.uk
badminton the fits Walmart Badminton
Club wish to recruit social players to
play on a regular basis
it's on Monday 7 30 to 9 30 PM it takes
place on Four Courts at the daily Cox
Sports Hall at fitzwimark school in
Rayleigh contact the fits warm-up
Badminton Club chairman on
01268-771914 or email
worships at talktalk.net
Cricket rankings Cricket Club run by
qualified coaches will be meeting
through the winter
all are welcome
it's on Mondays from 7pm until 8 pm at
greenswater Academy Sports Hall and
caters for age groups from under nines
to under 15s it costs three pounds each
per evening contact 01702
257005 or 0786
the roach art group all abilities
catered For Good lighting and Facilities
membership inquiries welcome it's on
Wednesdays from 7 30 p.m until 9 30 pm
at St Theresa's Parish Center Hall
ashington Road Rochford and the entrance
is via the school gates with the hall
being located to the rear of the church
reasonable fees apply and there are
details on request you can contact Jill
on
07968-745-975 or John on 07933-263-930
The Institute of advanced motorists is a
friendly local Group which meets to
discuss motoring and road safety issues
on the first Wednesday evening of every
other month at the Hockley Community
Center and the contact is Gene Mansell
on 01268
-754-9 double two
active 50 plus classes the fun way to
get active and keep healthy all
abilities welcome
Thursdays 1 30 p.m in the Hockley Health
Club
Fridays 9 30 a.m at the hawkwell Baptist
Church Hall and Fridays at 10 A.M at the
great wakering Community Center there's
no need to book just come along and join
in there is a contact number
0740-626-226 or you could contact
www.activelife.uk.com
Thursday art group this small friendly
art group is suitable for all abilities
it's on Thursday afternoons between 1 30
and 4 30 p.m at the old fire station
Hockley contact Colin gammon01 702
204-706
the Recycled teenagers forum is a
friendly and welcoming group providing
encouragement and support for people
over 40 to access activities and day
trips at affordable prices
Fridays 11 A.M until 11 45 am at the wi
Hall Rochford Square
aerobics will cost two pounds 50 for
members three pounds for non-members
contact us for membership and trip
information on
616-619 or 0792-207-724
we can also be contacted at recycled
teenagers at
live.co.uk and the website is
www.recycled teenagers.org dot UK
Family Theater Arthur's Dreamboat Arthur
has an amazing dream about a beautiful
pink and green boat
based on Polly dunbar's book this
playful show features breathtaking
puppets and music by Tom Gray of the
winning band Gomez
recommended age three to seven
this is on Monday no sorry on Sunday
February the 8th 2015 between 11 A.M and
2PM at the Mill arts and events center
the tickets are four pounds each and the
booking number is
01702 318-191
Council and committee meetings all
meetings will take place at the Civic
Suite 2 Hockley Road Rayleigh ss6 8eb
starting at 7 30 pm and for more
information call member services on
01702 318140
the development committee meet on
December the 18th 2014 January the 29th
and February the 26th 2015. the
executive January the 7th and February
the 4th
full Council December the 16th 2014
February the 10th and 24th 2015.
the Review Committee January the 6th and
February the 3rd 2015 and the treasury
management task and finish group January
the 27th 2015.
Sports and Leisure Rochford District
Health walks take place on when Mondays
at 10 45 a.m in holbridge meeting the
car park on the corner of Ferry Road and
Paul's Lane bus route number 20.
and Thursdays at 10 45 a.m in Hockley
Woods meeting the pay and display car
park entrance next to the bull bus
routes number seven or eight
February half term holiday activities
are from February the 16th to the 20th
check
www.rochford.gov dot UK forward slash
holiday activities nearer the time for
more information
and Rockford District disability Sports
sessions are a regular weekly session
when they will start at stanbridge
Memorial Hall this winter for further
information and notification of dates
and times contact Mark aldus Sports
Development officer Rochford District
Council
318121 or email sport
rochford.gov dot UK
please note that although events are
checked before going to press they are
subject to change we recommend you visit
our website at
www.rochford.gov dot UK or contact the
organizers to check before going to an
event
pledge for Plastics
we are urging residents to recycle more
Plastics
you know that you can recycle all
plastic bottles plastic tubs pots trays
and plastic carrier bags in your gray
recyclables bin
an estimated 2.5 million tons of plastic
packaging is used in the UK each year by
recycling your plastic this reduces the
need to use virgin plastic resin oil to
make new Plastics we want residents to
pledge to recycle one more plastic item
per week this could be anything a
plastic bottle including shampoo and
cleaning product bottles plastic meat
trays yogurt pots margarine tubs ice
cream tubs and vegetable and fruit
punnets these can all be recycled in
your recyclables bin for a full list of
what can be recycled visit
www.rochford.gov dot UK forward slash
recycling
as part of a national pledge for
Plastics campaign you can pledge to
recycle more Plastics at
www.pledge4 that's a figure four
Plastics dot Co dot UK forward slash
pledge join the thousands of UK
residents who have already pledged reuse
your Plastics lots of items can be
reused again such as clothing and
furniture but do reuse your Plastics
a simple way to reuse plastic bottles is
to use them again water and drinks
bottles can be refilled and they can be
reused in the garden plastic pots and
tubs can be used for storage such as for
freezing leftovers or for storing arts
and crafts materials this way you can
also save money by not buying storage
boxes
the recycling journey of a plastic
bottle have you ever wondered what
happens to your empty bottles once you
pop it in the recyclables bin
follow this journey to find out how your
unwanted plastic is reborn as a great
new product
your empty plastic bottle is placed in
the recycling bin the recycling truck
takes it to the Sorting Center
the bottles are sorted to different
material types
mailing machines squash the bottles and
make solid blocks called bales
the bottles are then shredded into
flakes which are washed in a big
whirlpool bath to clean off the labels
and dirt
the flakes are sorted again depending on
whether they float or sink
giant industrial dryers dry the flakes
which are blown down pipes into bags or
boxes
the sorted plastic is ready to be passed
on to the recyclers and manufacturers
new products such as clothes duvets
garden furniture kids toys kitchen
utensils pens fencing and pipes are then
created
Rochford District Council has changed
its bank if you pay your bills by direct
debit your bank should automatically
amend your details to reflect this
change
standing order you will need to give
Rochford District councils new bank
details to your bank and their new
details are Lloyds Bank PLC the account
name is Rochford District Council the
sort code is 30 80 12 and the account
number is 1054-2560
Rochford District matters is designed
and published by Rochford District
Council its editor is Laura Bliss the
telephone number for the council is
01702-54-6366 and the magazine is
printed by Morton print limited
01507-52-3456 this recording has been
produced by volunteers from Rayleigh
Rochford and castlepoint talking
newspaper
registering to vote the way we all
register to vote has changed the voter
registration system changed in June 2014
the news system is called individual
electoral registration known as ier
by now you should have received a letter
from US letting you know that either
your details have been confirmed and
successfully transferred to the new
system and you don't need to do anything
further or you need to provide us with
additional information in order to be
registered under ier and have been sent
an invitation to register form if you
have recently moved house you may not be
registered you can now register online
at
www.gov.uk forward slash register hyphen
2 hyphen vote
for more information please phone the
elections officer on 01702
318187 your vote matters make sure
you're in
Rochford area action plan
for the future of Rochford Market Square
have been changed as a direct response
to Residence feedback
this follows a consultation between
March and may this year which included
having an exhibition stall at Rochford
Market
two options were presented but following
your feedback both plans have been
dropped in favor of one that better
reflects local views
the two options initially suggested each
took different approaches to the Market
Square however whilst neither option
involved complete pedestrianization
responses to the public consultation
made clear just how important it is to
have car parking available to businesses
and visitors as such an alternative
option has been drawn up which increases
rather than reduces the number of
parking spaces in the Square
proposed changes to the Market Square
form part of the Rochford area action
plan the plan that will set out how
future development in the center of
Rochford is managed
this plan was submitted to government
for examination in November 2013 but
following the examination hearing
sessions options for the Market Square
were looked at again
proposed changes also include switching
the entrance and exit to the parking
area after a number of residents
suggested this
proposals for the Market Square along
with other changes proposed to the
Rochford area action plan as a result of
the examination hearing sessions are set
out in the schedule of modifications
which were out for public consultation
until noon on December the 4th
the main purpose of the consultation was
for people who made comments on the
previous version of the plan to be given
a chance to say whether they think their
concerns have been addressed however
anyone May comment on the proposed
changes to the plan and we welcome
comments from everyone
more information on the consultation on
the schedule of modifications to the
Rochford area action plan including how
to respond can be found online at
www.rochford.gov dot UK forward slash
Raa plan in Rochford library or at
Rochford district council's offices
Sports Awards winners
talented local sports stars were
recognized at the Rochford and Castle
Point Sports Awards 2014 sponsored by
Pinnacle PSG
the winners were announced at a Gala
ceremony organized by Rochford District
Council and castlepoint Borough Council
chairman of Rochford District Council
councilor June Lumley said we are lucky
to have such a wealth of local sporting
Talent this year nominees included world
champions British Champions Commonwealth
Games athletes and European Champions as
well as those who have spent decades
giving up their spare time to volunteer
I would really like to thank all the
nominees for their efforts as well as
those who made this event such a success
and these are the winners
sports Personality of the Year sponsored
by Wells legal solicitors the Rochford
District Lucy Hodges MBE and for
castlepoint Paige Curson
young sports Personality of the Year
sponsored by South End United Community
and educational trust Robert ransoman
for Rochford and James EAD for Castle
point
disability sports Personality of the
Year sponsored by Waters and Stanton
limited Matthew Oten for Rochford and
Matthew Hamilton for Castle point
services to sport sponsored by The
Cooperative funeral care Mike worship
for Rochford Clive Hopkins for
castlepoint
Rochford 2012 respect award and Castle
Point respect award both sponsored by
Affinity 1777
Dave record for Rochford and heart and
soul cardiac Rehabilitation for
castlepoint
Sports Club of the Year sponsored by
Fusion lifestyle
rankins Cricket Club for Rochford and
Special Olympics Essex for castlepoint
the Rochford District Council Chairman's
award sponsored by councilor Mrs June
Lumley was Matthew Lee and the castle
Point Borough Council mayor's award
sponsored by councilor Mrs Jackie govia
Lauren ban
the sports
the Year award was a well-deserved win
for Lucy Hodges having just achieved a
gold medal in the ifds blind match
racing World Championships in 2014. Lucy
and her team won all 13 of their races
at the event in Sheboygan Wisconsin USA
it has been an incredible run for Lucy
who received an MBE for her services to
Blind sailing in the Queen's New Year's
honors list a gold medal in 2013 at the
ifds blind World sailing championships
in Japan and gold at the blind match
racing championships in Italy earlier
this year
she also runs the charity Great Britain
blind sailing and was previously awarded
Rochford District sports Personality of
the year in 2010
. Lucy said I think it's good kudos for
the local authority to run something
like the sports awards as they help to
develop people in the local community
to see me getting an award encourages
youngsters and others with a disability
as they can have someone to look to
locally and have a bit of drive and
ambition it's also good for parents of a
child born with a disability to see
someone where it hasn't stopped them in
life they've got a job and a sporting
career
the allocations plan
a member of the public launched a legal
challenge against the adoption of the
allocations plan earlier this year
and the council are currently awaiting
the Court's judgment
the allocations plan is one of the key
documents against which planning
applications are determined
it allocates land for a range of uses
including housing and Employment
Development as well as allocating land
so that it is protected from development
it is required to conform to the
Rochford core strategy
and includes the allocation of specific
sites for development in the General
locations identified through the core
strategy
in short the challenge relates to
whether consultation on the plan and
consultation on a technical document
that accompanies the plan was adequate
the claim has taken longer to hear than
was initially expected
but hearing sessions have now concluded
we await the Court's judgment and we
have not been given a time scale for
this
as such the council is not able to
comment further on the matter until the
judge has made his decision
in the meantime the policies in the
allocations plan remain in place
as there has been no application to have
them suspended before the judgment is
made
and to view the allocations plan in full
go to
www.rochfood.gov dot UK forward slash
allocations
the ancient Woodlands
if you have ever walked in woods filled
with bluebells then you have probably
been in some of the oldest Woodland in
Britain
Britain has around 12 percent of
Woodland cover making it one of the
least wooded countries in the EU
the majority of Forestry commission
plantations and secondary Woodland
filled with quick growing Spruce and
Pine
sadly only two percent is ancient
Woodland because much of it has been
lost due to farming food reduction and
housing since the first World War
we are fortunate to have Hockley Woods
in our district a mosaic of a joining
Woods creating the largest continuous
ancient ward in Essex
so why cut down trees if our Woods were
connected and larger they would be
self-supporting natural processes such
as storms and grazing animals would
create clearings allowing sunlight to
penetrate this balance of light and
shade cultivates many rare flowers and
creatures
sadly our ancient Woods are now too
small and isolated to provide enough of
these natural nurseries
ancient Woodland contains more rare and
endangered species than any other
terrestrial habitat in the UK
many such as bluebells wooden enemies
and the common door Mouse rely on wild
rides and coppice processes for their
existence left unmanaged trees grow
forming a dense canopy and plants lose
their battle for light it neglected was
the variety and numbers of species
declines and are eventually lost
so what is coppicing native hardwood
trees are cut and New Growth develops
providing a sustainable Timber crop this
process can prolong the life of a tree
by centuries
many old trees show signs of previous
management a copis lime tree at West
Bert Arboretum is estimated to be around
6 000 years old
opinions about copacing very greatly
some call it deforestation others
delightful each season the variety of
vegetation creates attractive Woodland
alive with creatures
Sudden Change to a beloved walk or
favorite spot can be heartfelt but very
few people fail to appreciate the new
flowers and Wildlife that appear in
recently copised areas
hockleywood's importance was championed
in the early 1900s by the then Rochford
rural District Council who said about
preserving and purchasing some of the
remaining local ancient Woodlands
Hockley bets and kingley woods
the wood's importance is now recognized
nationally by being designated as a site
of special scientific interest all
conservation work are strictly
controlled by Natural England and the
forestry Commission
focus on bluebells the native species
higher Synthroid is non-scripta has dark
flowers in one-sided nodding rasimes
with strongly recurved petals and white
ansas pollen
the Spanish bluebells hyacinthoides
hispanica has pale of flowers produced
on all sides of the upright stem less
recurved petals and blue anthers pollen
bluebells indicate that a site is or
once was ancient Woodland
Britain's Woods contain 50 of the
world's bluebells
as a protected species it is illegal to
pick bluebells and please stay on the
paths to avoid trampling
there's a legend that bluebells ring to
summon fairies
archaeological evidence has shown that
bluebells have been used as glue to
attach feathers to arrows as book
binding glue and to stem pleading
the environment flood Forum takes action
residents have been attending meetings
organized by Rochford District Council
to address local flooding issues
the forum for surface water flooding
issues were set up to bring together
organizations including Essex highways
anglian water the environment agency and
the Essex County Council flood
management team for an in-depth
discussion about how to resolve issues
across the district
Rochford District Council is not
responsible for flooding issues but
created The Forum in an attempt to help
resolve issues for residents
the aim of the group is to find out who
is responsible for various water courses
ditches and drains
and then try to ensure that those
responsibilities are complied with
Rochford District council's principal
engineer has visited various sites where
flooding has occurred to try to identify
the source of the problem and speak with
some of the affected residents before
passing his findings on to the relevant
agency to resolve Essex County Council
the environment agency and anglian water
are also undertaking to resolve flooding
issues in streets across the district
at these Forum meetings residents have
directly raised concerns about problem
areas which the agencies agreed to
review as a matter of urgency
Rochford District Council had previously
budgeted 18
000 pounds towards tackling surface
water drainage this will now be eligible
for a match funding offer from Essex
County Council who are offering up to 50
000 pounds to tackle local flooding
issues
at the last meeting about 30 locations
were discussed in relation to
maintenance Works tracking down of
responsible landowners high pressure
jetting camera surveys and installing
screens
Rochford District Council also voted to
fund the digging of a new ditch to the
rear of blower close in Rayleigh in an
effort to protect residents homes from
flooding
although this is not the responsibility
of the district council the decision was
taken in order to expedite matters as so
many residents and landowners were
potentially affected
for a list of streets discussed by The
Forum visit
www.rochford.gov dot UK forward slash
press releases
this Summit for local businesses
more than 70 Business people attended
the Rochford District skills Summit
delegates spoke with Specialists from
across the education training and
recruitment sectors to understand more
about apprenticeships Business
Development training funding and staff
on hand to provide information and
advice were exhibitors including 360
Degrees Essex County Council ixion
Holdings Jobcentre Plus low carbon
business National Apprentice service
National skills academy for retail read
ncfe ravs Salvation Army Employment
Services Civic South Essex college and
South End Adult Community College
briefing sessions were also provided on
key topics of Interest such as how to
utilize the South Essex growth Grant how
to utilize the skills support for the
Workforce program
how a work-ready young person can help
your business
how to utilize an apprentice to expand
your business and how to utilize
volunteers
the free event sponsored by low carbon
business was part of Rochford District
council's very successful business
breakfast program
the mill arts and events center
Friday the 19th and Saturday the 20th of
December Christmas party night 7 pm to
midnight
phone oh one two six eight double seven
eight one seven one to book
Sunday the 21st of December lost in
Christmas and entertainment showcase
doors open at 7 30 PM for further
details email info at Famous
entertainments.co.uk
Sunday the 28th of December Rayleigh
windmill open day between midday and 2PM
Wednesday the 31st of December New
Year's Eve party 7 30 pm to 1 30 am
phone oh one two six eight double seven
eight one seven one to book
Saturday the 10th of January 2015 Vicki
wellness fitness day between 9am and 4pm
Sunday the 25th of January and Sunday
the 22nd of February indoor boot sale
between 9am and 2PM
Friday the 6th of February Jason
manford's comedy night at 8 pm
Sunday the 8th of February Arthur's
Dreamboat more information later and
Saturday the 28th of February Pink Floyd
tribute band 6 30 to 11 30 pm
please note that although events are
checked before going to press they are
subject to change we recommend you visit
our website at
www.rochford.gov dot UK for updates